finally the phillies yankee series gets
underway
out of about a week's delay joe gerardi
brings his phillies into the bronx where
he managed for 10 years and a couple of
those years he managed this guy
and his former teammate d.d gregorius
gets a look from the other side
girardi's been
excellent this last week yeah i know
it's been hard for everybody to see his
numbers when he's with the yankees it's
been hard for the phillies players not
playing since last sunday the phillies
have not played in
eight days since july 26th that's
gary cole gonna make his 195th
career start this is the first one in
pinstripes
towing that slab into boogie down so
welcome to the bronx gary cole
cole the top free agent signing during
the off season
and harper the previous offseason he's
in the second year with the fills
2-2 tipped into the glove of sanchez an
impressive one two three inning
dj le mayhew leads it off for the x and
he'll face the
phil's right-hander jake arrieta
hey slide the right deep right harper at
the track harper at the wall
she's gone oh the dj
spitting a tune right off the bat
tonight
let me hue adios amigo
is second home run of the season and
welcome back to active duty philadelphia
phillies right off the bat it's one to
nothing new york how about the round of
applause the fake crowd noise just gave
dd well respected in new york definitely
well respected between innings the
yankees
had a dd tribute on the big board in
center field a lot of great moments with
the aim well between innings the yankees
played a
video highlight package of joe giordi's
career that i'm sure if there was a
crowd there they would have
acknowledged it a lot of wins for a
story franchise
okay bruce 26 homers a year ago
out towards center field it's carrying
pretty well and
it is gone into the bullpen
jay bruce with his first home run of the
year
now the phillies have tied this game up
at one now that is a big league
professional at bat
1-1 bottom of the third inning gartner
just one hit in
16 at bats that one hit was a home run
though he has two ribbies
skied the other way on the run is
mccutcheon and that ball is gone
and opposite field home run power the
other way by gardner i told you tonight
this ball is traveling all the baseballs
that get up a little bit are going to
move with this humidity tonight and
gardner went the opposite way and the
yankees lead two to one
judge with a single center solid base in
his first time up
hit sharply to third and under the glove
of segura and down into the left field
corner
judge has himself a double and he will
stop right there single and a double for
judge today
you know everything in this at bat was a
way away away and then you try to get in
and aaron judge is able
while supposed to be away you see it run
in is able to get to cover
all of the plate which to me just means
he is so comfortable with the plate he
doesn't have to guess
in or out just pick up the baseball put
a good swing on it
you're talking about a guy that's six
seven 280 and being able to get to an
inside sinker like this and
shorten up and bring his hands in that's
amazing so runner at second for aaron
hicks with two outs
that one is laced in the left center
field that's gonna be a base hit that'll
score
judge easily going for two as hicks and
he will make it with a double and rbi
it's three
one units d.d gregory is coming up with
two outs
dede swings and pops one up in the
infield a mile high
let's see who calls for it le mayhew on
the infield grass dj makes the catch to
retire the side
yankees three phillies one so here is
urshela he's over two tonight
geo flies one deep to left mccutchen
going back
on the track mccutchen in front of the
bullpen she's gone
geo urshella with two men aboard takes
guerra into the phillies bullpen adios
sami goal
and the bronx bombers continue to bash
the baseball
they lead six to one while the head
groundskeeper
danny cunningham showed the radar to
angel hernandez the crew chief
and um they said let's put the tarp on
yankees are seven and one
and they're trying to be eight and one
they lead six to one we're ready to roll
here after a somewhat lengthy rain delay
six innings in the book the yankees are
leading six to one it'll be segura bruce
and kingery
against krisky on a relief of garrett
cole adam heasley now the hitter
that one's out toward left center field
and it'll drop in front of hicks for a
base hit
one run scores it was booted a little
bit by hicks
and the phillies get one back it's now
six to two
what a net bat by adam hazley man alive
they spoiled some tough pitches
adam hazley picks up another hit and his
second rbi of the year and here comes
aaron boone
change for the yanks avilan here to face
gene segura
off the end of the bat flared towards
center that's in for a base hit
rounding third and heading to home as jt
he'll score it's an rpi single but it's
now a 6-3 game
any day now they could be getting back
or aldous chapman he's been off the
covet 19 list and obviously britain's
done a great job britain trying to nail
it down
right up the middle caught there by
lemayo and the yankees win
6-3 and it's another vic
wait a minute it smells like victory